As long as he could remember, going back to when he was a child, Sam was scared of spiders. But not scared in the normal way, where lots of us don't feel great when we see a big spider, or a snake, or a big bug, or whatever.
从他记事起，大概从童年时代开始，萨姆就怕蜘蛛。但不是那种普通意义上的怕，不是我们大多数人在看到大蜘蛛、蛇、大虫子之类的东西时感到不适的那种怕。
It invaded all aspects of my life at all points in the year. I was thinking about spiders all the time. Any room I walked into, I looked in the corners. I looked under the table, crouched down. Every night before I went to bed, I fully unmade my bed.
它侵入了我一年四季生活的方方面面。我无时无刻不在想蜘蛛。走进任何一个房间，我都会查看角落。我会查看桌子底下，蹲下来检查。每天晚上睡觉前，我都要把床完全拆开检查一遍。
Walking down the street, I wouldn't walk under anything that-- I would try to avoid right angles to the best I could, because that's where a spider is going to make its web.
走在街上，我不会从任何东西下面走过——我会尽我所能避开直角，因为那是蜘蛛结网的地方。
But you were scared that one would fall on you? Or just because that's where they are?
你是怕有蜘蛛掉在你身上吗？还是仅仅因为那是它们待的地方？
Whether or not it would fall on me was really irrelevant. Just seeing a spider, not moving, moving, large, small, it just created a feeling in my body that was just-- I would shake. I would throw up. I would faint. And of course, if you're constantly going through your life looking for spiders, you'll find one.
它会不会掉在我身上根本无关紧要。只要看到蜘蛛，不管它是动还是不动，是大还是小，我的身体就会产生一种感觉——我会发抖。我会呕吐。我会昏厥。当然，如果你在生活中总是试图寻找蜘蛛，你肯定会找到一只的。
As a kid, he didn't do sleepovers, didn't do summer camp. Other kids made fun of him. People did not understand. People pitied him.
小时候，他不参加过夜聚会，也不去夏令营。其他孩子取笑他。人们不理解他。人们同情他。
And when he grew up, it did not go away. His fear ruined dates. He once found a spider the size of your thumbnail in his car and sold the car that day.
当他长大成人后，这种恐惧并没有消失。他的恐惧毁了他的约会。他曾经在车里发现了一只拇指指甲大小的蜘蛛，当天就把车给卖了。
I had went to psychiatrists for exposure therapy. I had went to psychiatrists to talk about it. I couldn't watch an image of a spider on a TV screen.
我去看过精神科医生，进行暴露疗法。我也看过精神科医生去谈论这件事。我甚至无法在电视屏幕上看一眼蜘蛛的图像。
Let me ask you, does this name mean anything to you?
我问你，这个名字对你有什么意义吗？
Hmm?
嗯？
Peter Parker.
彼得·帕克（Peter Parker）。
No. Oh, oh, Spider Man.
不。哦，哦，蜘蛛侠。
Yeah, could you watch those films?
是的，你能看那些电影吗？
No, absolutely not. I don't even know if Spider Man has anything to do with spiders, to be honest.
不，绝对不行。老实说，我甚至不知道蜘蛛侠是否和蜘蛛有什么关系。
And then, he was seeing a hypnotherapist, and it was going nowhere, when he read in The New York Times about this new treatment for phobias that can get full results in just one day. And he reached out to the doctor behind it, a psychologist, Dr. Merel Kindt in Amsterdam. And she invited him to be part of a study and get the treatment. He figured he had nothing to lose and flew to The Netherlands. A film crew captured what happened during his treatment for a documentary series called A Cure for Fear.
后来，他去看了一位催眠治疗师，但毫无进展。这时他在《纽约时报》上读到了一种治疗恐惧症的新方法，只需一天就能取得全面疗效。他联系了背后的医生，一位在阿姆斯特丹的心理学家，梅雷尔·金特（Merel Kindt）博士。她邀请他参与一项研究并接受治疗。他想反正也没什么可失去的，于是飞往荷兰。一个摄制组记录了他治疗过程中发生的一切，制作成了一部名为《恐惧疗法》（A Cure for Fear）的纪录片系列。
You're doing fine.
你做得很好。
I'm so nervous.
我太紧张了。
Yeah, it's OK.
是的，没关系的。
Sam and Dr. Kindt stand outside the door of her room. She opens it. He looks in. There's an aquarium with a brown, furry tarantula, maybe 4 or 5 inches in size.
萨姆和金特博士站在她房间的门外。她打开门。他向里看去。里面有一个水族箱，有一只棕色、毛茸茸的狼蛛，大概有4到5英寸大。
Yes, there's a spider in the tank. But let's not wait too long. So it would be very good if you can already walk in the room, and then I close the door. Very good, great. We're doing very well.
是的，水箱里有一只蜘蛛。但我们不要等太久。所以如果你能先走进房间，然后我关上门，那就太好了。非常好，棒极了。我们做得非常出色。
I think you can hear that I was breathing hard, and I'm feeling that there is adrenaline. I crouch down, my arms crossed.
我想你能听出我在剧烈呼吸，我能感觉到肾上腺素在分泌。我蹲下来，双臂交叉。
Dr. Kindt then opens the door of the tank.
接着，金特博士打开了水箱的盖子。
Oh, whoa, god. No, no, no, you're not going to make me look in there, are you?
哦，哇，天哪。不，不，不，你不会真的要让我往那里看吧？
Yes, I'm going to ask you.
是的，我要请你看。
[HYPERVENTILATING]
[过度换气]
So please come with me. So step in here, and then close it. Very good. And then, can you also--
所以请跟我来。站到这里，然后关上门。非常好。然后，你能也——
Oh god!
哦，天哪！
Very good, very good. Yeah, come. And--
非常好，非常好。对，过来。然后——
No! Don't make me go in there!
不！别逼我进去！
Then, to get the spider to move around this tank, she sprays it with water. And every time she plays it with water, the spider waves its legs or moves around a little.
然后，为了让蜘蛛在水箱里走动，她用水喷它。每次她用水喷它，蜘蛛就会挥动腿或者稍微移动一下。
Yeah.
对。
OK. How high is your distress right now?
好的。你现在的痛苦程度有多高？
It's like 100.
大概100分。
OK, but it's very important not to move away.
好的，但是千万不要走开，这非常重要。
OK, I'm not moving away.
好的，我不会走开。
All right, spray it a bit so that--
好了，喷它一下，这样——
(SCREAMING) Oh, god, no! [WAILS]
[尖叫] 哦，天哪，不！[哀号]
Yeah, that's very good. OK.
对，这非常好。好的。
[HYPERVENTILATING] I gotta go!
[过度换气] 我得走了！
Sam, I'm wondering, like when you scream like this, I'm wondering what goes through your head.
萨姆，我很好奇，当你这样尖叫时，我在想你的脑子里在想什么。
That I feel like I can feel it on me, that I'm going to be attacked by it. None of this is rational, right?
我觉得我能感觉到它在我身上，我觉得我要被它攻击了。这一切都不理性，对吧？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I know it's not--
我知道它不是——
I know that the thing isn't going to jump out of the tank and move like 4 feet in the air and jump on me. I get that. But it doesn't matter, because I feel that the absolute worst things that can happen are going to happen and are, in fact, happening.
我知道那东西不会从水箱里跳出来，在空中飞4英尺扑到我身上。我明白。但那没关系，因为我觉得绝对最糟糕的事情即将发生，而且实际上正在发生。
The reason Dr. Kent wants him to max out on anxiety like this is that she wants to trigger the memories and feelings of fear of spiders that are stored in his brain. And then, when his brain goes to store this big new terrible experience with the old ones, it has to re-save the old memories. And she gives him a drug, a beta blocker called propranolol, that disrupts that process. And I know this sounds so simple. How can this be real? But by disrupting the way that the brain re-saves those memories, she neutralizes them.
金特博士想让他焦虑达到极限的原因是，她想触发储存在他大脑中对蜘蛛的记忆和恐惧感。然后，当他的大脑将这种巨大的、可怕的新体验与旧的记忆存储在一起时，它就必须重新保存旧的记忆。她给了他一种药物，一种叫做普萘洛尔（propranolol）的β受体阻滞剂，可以中断这个过程。我知道这听起来很简单。这怎么可能是真的呢？但通过破坏大脑重新保存这些记忆的方式，她中和了它们。
The very next day, Sam returns to the same room. He walks right in. His breathing is normal.
第二天，萨姆回到了同一个房间。他直接走了进去。呼吸正常。
There's fear in that-- well, I don't know that there's fear. I don't understand my feeling, because I've never been like this before.
这里面有恐惧——嗯，我不知道是否有恐惧。我不理解我的感觉，因为我以前从来没有这样过。
Nothing physically, internally, was happening that used to happen to.
身体内部没有发生任何过去常发生的事情。
You didn't feel the fear?
你没有感觉到恐惧吗？
I didn't feel the fear. And when she said--
我没有感觉到恐惧。当她说——
No adrenaline?
没有肾上腺素分泌？
No adrenaline at all. I felt, I guess, excitement that this was new.
完全没有肾上腺素。我想，我感到的是一种新鲜感。
You think you are able to touch it?
你觉得你能摸它吗？
And she says, do you want to pet it?
她说，你想摸摸它吗？
Let's make a deal.
我们做个交易吧。
And I said, look, if you hold my hand, I'll pet the spider. And I did. And I petted it, and the thing started to move. And then she's like, do you want to pet it again? And I said, yes.
我说，你看，如果你握着我的手，我就摸那只蜘蛛。我做了。我摸了它，那东西开始动了。然后她说，你想再摸一次吗？我说，是的。
You touched the tarantula!
你摸了那只狼蛛！
That was over three years ago, and Sam says the effect of the treatment has only deepened as he's had more calm interactions with spiders. He doesn't look around for spiders anymore everywhere he goes. And remember he once sold a car when he found a spider in it? He told me that the day before I interviewed him, he was driving in the SUV that he owns today, flipped down the mirror, a spider dropped into his lap. He was going 60. He said if that had happened back in the day, before the treatment, he really might have crashed his car. But now, he rolled down the window, picked up the spider, threw it outside.
那是三年多以前的事了，萨姆说，随着他与蜘蛛的互动变得更加平静，治疗的效果反而加深了。他再也不会去任何地方都查看有没有蜘蛛了。还记得他曾经因为在车里发现蜘蛛就把车卖了吗？他告诉我，在我采访他的前一天，他开着现在拥有的那辆SUV，翻下遮阳板时，一只蜘蛛掉进了他的膝盖上。他当时车速有60迈。他说，如果是在以前，治疗前，他真的可能会把车撞毁。但现在，他摇下车窗，捡起蜘蛛，把它扔到了外面。
Can you talk about just, like, how extreme the treatment was?
你能谈谈这次治疗有多极端吗？
I thought at one point I was going to have a heart attack and die in that room. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
我有那么一刻以为自己会心脏病发作死在那个房间里。[笑] 是的。
Does it seem right somehow that you would have to go through something so extreme to get over something so extreme?
为了克服极端的事物而必须经历如此极端的事情，这听起来合理吗？
It's what had to be done, fighting fire with fire.
这是必须要做的事，以毒攻毒。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Radiation therapy, it's your last resort option that you have to deal with a problem that can't be solved in any other way. This is the nuclear option.
放射疗法，这是你处理无法以其他方式解决的问题时的最后手段。这是“核选项”。
Well, today, our program, the nuclear option. We have stories where there's a problem, somebody decides to throw the book at it, go big, do everything they can think of. And we see what happens as a result to the people that the flying book is aimed at, but also the people it is not aimed at who get hit with it anyway. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm your friendly neighborhood radio host, Ira Glass. Stay with us.
那么，今天我们的节目就是“核选项”。我们会讲一些故事，当遇到问题时，有人决定全力以赴，孤注一掷，尽其所能。我们要看看结果如何——不仅是对那些被“飞书”瞄准的人，也对那些即使没被瞄准也难免遭殃的人。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是你们友好的邻家广播主持人艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act 1, "Catching Deer, When You Wanted Lions." So we begin with an example of the United States Congress seeing a problem and then using all its powers, doing everything it can, moving decisively to eliminate the problem forever. The problem they were solving in this case? Well, prostitution is illegal in America, but there were millions of ads for it online, some of them advertising women and children who were held by sex traffickers. Congress wanted to stop the sex traffickers' ads.
第一幕，“捕捉鹿，却想要狮子。”我们先从一个例子开始：美国国会发现了一个问题，然后利用其所有权力，尽其所能，果断行动以彻底消除该问题。他们在这个案例中要解决的问题是什么？嗯，卖淫在美国是非法的，但网上有数百万条相关广告，其中一些广告招募的是被性贩运者控制的妇女和儿童。国会想要取缔性贩运者的广告。
So that's a goal I think most people would agree with. A law passes with overwhelming majorities, House and Senate. One of our producers, Lina Misitzis has been looking into how things played out from that point-- with the people that the law is supposed to help, victims of sex trafficking, but also with other people who are not the official target of the law.
我认为这是一个大多数人都会赞同的目标。这项法律在众议院和参议院以压倒性多数通过。我们的制片人之一琳娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）一直在观察从那时起事情是如何发展的——不仅是对法律本应帮助的人，即性贩运受害者，还有那些并非该法律正式目标的人。
We're going to hear the story of one woman who was trafficked, and then you're going to hear the story of the law, and then, after that, the story of how the law actually affected her. Warning to listeners-- there is no explicit content in this story at all, but it does talk about sex and sex trafficking. Here's Lina.
我们要听的是一个曾经被贩运的女性的故事，然后你会听到关于这项法律的故事，之后是这项法律如何实际影响了她的故事。提醒听众——这个故事中没有任何露骨的内容，但确实讨论了性和性贩运。这是琳娜的报道。
When people hear the phrase "sex trafficking," I think a lot of the time, a kind of cartoonish version of it pops up in their heads. Let me tell you what it meant in Kara's case. We'll start in 2006 when she was 17, a runaway in Orlando working at a pizza place. She decided to try becoming a stripper, figuring it would be better money, but she really didn't know anything about it. She had no idea what she was doing.
当人们听到“性贩运”这个词时，我想大多数时候，脑海中浮现的是一种卡通般的版本。让我告诉你在卡拉（Kara）的案例中这意味着什么。我们从2006年开始，当时她17岁，是奥兰多一家披萨店的离家出走者。她决定尝试成为一名脱衣舞娘，觉得赚钱会更多，但她对这一行一无所知。她根本不知道自己在做什么。
To prepare for her first shift she went dress shopping, found a prom dress she liked.
为了准备第一次轮班，她去买衣服，挑了一件她喜欢的舞会礼服。
Yeah, it was a purple dress. I got it from Macy's.
是的，那是一件紫色的裙子。我是在梅西百货买的。
Was it like floor length?
是落地长裙吗？
Yeah, it was floor length, and it came right over my knees. It was a halter top. And I'm just looking, and I see all these girls, and they're in fishnets and clear heels. And this was about the time there was a song. It's called "Apple-Bottom Jeans," [LAUGHS] the boots with the fur. So I kind of just did what I could and jumped on a pole, and I slid down. But it wasn't like a sexy stripper slide. It was like holding on for dear life and kind of bouncing down. [LAUGHS]
是的，是落地长裙，刚过膝盖。那是挂脖款的。我环顾四周，看到所有的女孩都穿着网眼袜，蹬着透明高跟鞋。那时正流行一首歌，叫《Apple-Bottom Jeans》，[笑] 配着带皮毛的靴子。所以我尽量模仿她们，跳上钢管滑了下来。但那不像性感舞娘的滑落，倒像是拼命抓住钢管，蹦蹦跳跳地滑下来。[笑]
Kara found her footing soon enough. Actually, she really liked the job. The tips were good, she made more money than she'd ever made, and she liked the attention she got doing it. A few months later, another stripper at the club told her about a job in New York that paid even better. All she had to do was go out on dates with men.
卡拉很快就适应了。事实上，她真的很喜欢这份工作。小费很丰厚，她赚的钱比以前多得多，而且她喜欢这份工作带来的关注。几个月后，俱乐部里的另一名脱衣舞娘告诉她纽约有一份工作，报酬更高。她只需要和男人约会就行了。
Kara understood the job was something called escorting. She did not understand that escorting meant having sex. In any case, she got on a plane-- her very first-- and flew to White Plains, New York. A guy I'll call Larry paid for her ticket. The next morning, he took her on a drive down to Brooklyn.
卡拉明白那份工作叫“伴游”。她不知道伴游意味着发生性关系。不管怎样，她上了飞机——那是她平生第一次飞行——飞往纽约白原市。一个我称之为拉里（Larry）的家伙支付了机票。第二天早上，他开车带她去了布鲁克林。
We went to Junior's Cheesecake. I'll never forget it. He was trying to explain what escorting was, and I was so, I call it, green, like oblivious, naive to the fact of what it was, that I remember, like, well, how do we get our nails done? You know, how much tips do we get to keep, or like, how much money do we get to keep? And he just laughed. [LAUGHS]
我们去了Junior's芝士蛋糕店。我永远不会忘记。他试图解释什么是伴游，而我，怎么说呢，太“菜鸟”了，完全天真，对此一无所知，以至于我还问，我们怎么去做指甲？你知道，我们能留下多少小费，或者说，我们能拿到多少钱？他只是笑。[笑]
Because you're asking the kinds of questions that were relevant like at, like, the strip club, but not necessarily in this.
因为你问的问题就像是在脱衣舞俱乐部里问的，不一定是这种工作。
Yeah, like a tip-out, like what's the tip-out? And he just laughed. He knew, no matter what, you know, I was gonna do it. I was 18.
是的，就像是小费怎么分。他只是笑了。他知道，不管怎样，我都会干的。我当时18岁。
Next, Larry took Kara back to a La Quinta Inn. He had her pose in her underwear, took pictures he'd later post online in an escorting ad, and then, Larry said, it was time for her first date.
接下来，拉里带卡拉回到了速8酒店（La Quinta Inn）。他让她穿着内衣摆姿势，拍了照片，后来这些照片被发到了网上的伴游广告中。然后，拉里说，她的第一次约会时间到了。
What was he telling you the work would actually be?
他当时告诉你这份工作到底是做什么的？
That, basically, I would just be hanging out with people, like I said. He told me that I was going to have a date. This is, I'm 18 years old. I'm going to have a date. So I don't know what it is. I had just smoked some weed, and he left the room.
他基本上说，我只是和人待在一起。他说我要去约会。我当时18岁。我要去约会。所以我不知道那是什么。我刚抽了一些大麻，他就离开了房间。
A guy knocks on the door, and I let him in. And when I let him in, he pretty much coaches me through this whole-- like this whole day. And so the money was exchanged. He basically told me where to put the money.
一个人敲门，我让他进来了。当他进来时，他几乎指导我完成了这一整天——这一整天。然后钱交换了。他基本上告诉了我把钱放在哪里。
They had sex. Later, Kara told me that once it was happening, the first feeling she had was, oh, of course escorting means sex. And she felt shame, like what had she gotten herself into? When Kara was a kid, she was sexually abused by a family member and had the courage to come forward about it. She was in middle school. Here at the La Quinta Inn, six years later, she didn't even know who she'd report this to or how to describe what was happening, so she detached.
他们发生了性关系。后来，卡拉告诉我，一旦事情发生了，她产生的第一感觉是：哦，原来伴游确实意味着性交易。她感到羞耻，心想自己到底卷入了什么事情？卡拉小时候曾被家人性虐待，并有勇气站出来举报。那时她在读初中。六年后的今天，在这里，在速8酒店，她甚至不知道该向谁报告这件事，也不知道如何描述正在发生的事情，所以她选择了抽离。
The one thing she remembers clearly is a piece of advice the client gave her that night, which, Kara says, she'd recite in her head whenever seeing any client from then on.
她唯一清楚记得的是那天晚上客户给她的一条建议，卡拉说，从那以后，每次见客户，她都会在脑海里背诵这段话。
He was getting ready to leave. And I told him, all right, I'll see you later. And when I said that, he was like, no. You never just let somebody walk out on their own. You always walk them to the door, and you shut the door behind them. You never just let somebody just walk out, because anybody could come in after them. You know, they could be holding a door for somebody, whatever.
他准备离开了。我说，好吧，回头见。当我这么说时，他说，不。你永远不要让任何人自己离开。你一定要把他送到门口，然后在他身后关上门。你永远不要让任何人就这样走掉，因为谁都可能跟着进来。你知道，他们可能在帮别人挡门，不管是什么情况。
So I walked him to the door, and I shut the door. And when I shut the door, I broke down. Later on, I had found out that he was actually one of his homeboys. He was one of his friends.
于是我把他送到门口，关上了门。当我关上门时，我崩溃了。后来我发现他其实是拉里的哥们之一。他是拉里的朋友之一。
One of Larry's friends.
拉里的朋友之一。
And he had basically sent his friend in to have sex with me and to teach me what to do.
他基本上是派他的朋友进来跟我发生关系，并教我该做什么。
In the next few weeks, she says, she realized Larry was part of a gang. When I asked her, how did you figure that out, she laughed, explained, it's not like some big cinematic reveal. Just after that night, the camera started to zoom out. She met lots of Karas assigned to lots of Larrys. She was just one piece of the assembly line.
接下来的几周里，她说她意识到拉里是一个帮派的成员。当我问她是怎么发现的，她笑了，解释说这不像电影里那种盛大的揭秘。在那晚之后，镜头开始拉远。她遇到了许多分配给许多“拉里”的“卡拉”。她只是装配线上的一件零件。
I wanted to go home, but I had-- at that point, I couldn't call my family. I couldn't call anybody. I was stuck, and it was basically, all right, you've got to do what you have to do to eventually make it back home. I wasn't tied up to a bed. I wasn't drugged. I was just shamed, and I was scared, and I was terrified. And when I found out what I had actually been introduced to, into a whole gang, like the intimidation-- if you go home, then we're going to do this and that-- it just, it stuck me there. And that was the beginning of just a whirlwind in my life.
我想回家，但在那时，我不能给家人打电话。我谁也不能联系。我被困住了，基本上就是，好吧，你得做你必须做的事才能最终回到家。我没有被绑在床上。我没有被下药。我只是感到羞耻，我很害怕，我非常恐惧。当我发现我被带进了什么——带进了一个整个帮派，那种威胁——如果你回家，我们就会这样那样——它就把我困在那里了。那是我生活中旋风般生活的开始。
From then on, Larry was in charge of what Kara ate, who she had sex with, and where she went. She and Larry traveled around the country, strategically targeting places that attract a crowd.
从那时起，拉里掌控着卡拉吃什么、和谁发生性关系、去哪里。她和拉里在全国各地奔波，战略性地瞄准吸引人群的地方。
Were you making pennies on a dollar? Like were you making any percentage? Like you weren't getting to pocket any of this money?
你赚到的钱只有几分几毫吗？你有任何比例的提成吗？你根本拿不到这些钱？
No, no. And if you get caught stashing money, oh my gosh, you're getting your ass beat. I don't care if it's $20, no.
不，没有。如果你被发现私藏钱财，哦天哪，你会挨一顿毒打。我不管是不是20美元，不行。
So if you needed something--
那么如果你需要什么东西——
He would let you go to the store, and he would get it for you, or whatever. But what did you really need, other than own food or condoms? You know, you get clothes. You know, they take you-- you all go as a group, get your nails done, get your hair done.
他会让你去商店，或者他会帮你买，等等。但除了食物或避孕套，你真正需要什么？你知道，你有衣服。他们带你——你们一起去，做指甲，做头发。
Did you have friends?
你有朋友吗？
Yeah, you have friends, but they're called your wife-in-laws. They're other girls that are working. You don't have normal friends. You completely withdraw and isolate from anything and everybody that you knew.
是的，你有朋友，但她们被称为“共妻”。她们是其他在工作的女孩。你没有正常的朋友。你完全退缩并与你认识的所有事物和所有人隔绝。
So break it down in layman's terms. You're being raped all day, and you're not getting nothing out of it but some nails, or your hair done, or whatever it is to look good for the nice John, client, trick, whatever you want to call him.
那么用外行的话来说就是：你整天被强奸，除了做做指甲或发型，或者为了让那些体面的客户满意而做的任何事，你一无所获。
I asked Kara a lot of what-if questions, naively, about a lot of different scenarios. What if you try just getting up and leaving, taking a day off, getting a boyfriend? Then what? And her answer was always the same-- you'd get beat up.
我天真地问了卡拉很多关于不同场景的假设性问题。如果你尝试站起来离开、休个假、交个男朋友会怎样？那时会怎样？她的回答总是一样的——你会挨揍。
She'd never heard the term "sex trafficking." At that time, a lot of people hadn't, but that's what this was. Kara was being sex trafficked. She would be for another seven years.
她以前从未听说过“性贩运”这个词。当时，很多人都没听说过，但这正是所发生的事情。卡拉正在被性贩运。这种情况持续了另外七年。
Sex trafficking is any time someone is forced or coerced into a sex act where money is exchanged. They could be brought across state lines or international borders, but that doesn't have to be a part of it. While she was being trafficked, Kara had a quota, an amount of money she was supposed to bring in for the gang.
性贩运是指任何时候有人被强迫或胁迫参与金钱交易的性行为。他们可能被跨州或跨越国际边境，但这并不是必须的。在被贩运期间，卡拉有一个配额，这是她必须为帮派赚取的金额。
I had a $1,000 a day quota. You had to make $1,000 each day before you could go to sleep.
我每天的配额是1000美元。你每天必须赚到1000美元才能去睡觉。
She could bring in $1,000 by saying three clients in a day, each for an hour, or six a day, each for half an hour. The traffickers found clients for Kara by advertising online on Craigslist, and later on a website called Backpage. Whenever arriving anywhere new, they'd post a local ad for Kara. It would include photos of her and a short description. Guys would see the ads and book appointments. If the online ads didn't attract enough business, her trafficker would take her to truck stops or bars and have her try picking up clients there.
她可以通过一天接待三位客户（每人一小时），或者一天六位（每人半小时）来赚到1000美元。贩运者通过在Craigslist以及后来的Backpage网站上打广告来为卡拉寻找客户。无论到达哪里，他们都会为卡拉发布当地广告。广告包括她的照片和简短描述。男人们看到广告后会预约。如果在线广告吸引的生意不够多，她的贩运者会带她去卡车停靠站或酒吧，让她尝试在那里拉客。
Don't get it twisted. If you make $1,000 and it's only 12:00 PM, you're not off for the day. You're going to continuously be forced to make more money. But the $1,000 was just like, OK, you have to have this every day. I don't care if it's slow on the lines, go get it. Go find it.
别搞错了。如果你在中午12点就赚到了1000美元，你这一天并没有结束。你会被持续强迫赚更多的钱。但1000美元就像是一个底线，好吧，你每天必须有这个数。我不管生意有多淡，去弄到它。去找它。
Kara said she was traded between gangs three times, which, while she was explaining that, she actually gestured at a tattoo on her chest.
卡拉说她在帮派之间被交易了三次，在解释时，她指了指胸前的纹身。
That's the brand on my chest.
这是我胸前的烙印。
What is it?
那是什么？
The brand on my chest. This is-- you see the blood dripping, and it's for the Blood gang. It's Sex, Money, Murder.
我胸前的烙印。这是——你看那些滴落的血，这是为了血帮（Blood gang）。是“性、金钱、谋杀”。
It's a red heart with a spike through it, and the tip of the heart is bleeding. In the center of the heart, there is a person's name.
这是一个中间有尖刺刺穿的红心，心的尖端在流血。在心脏的中心，有一个人的名字。
That was his actual government name. I don't want to say that on record.
那是他真实的政府名字。我不想在记录中说出来。
On either side of those dots?
那两个点两边的是什么？
Snake eyes.
蛇眼（Snake eyes）。
Snake eyes. The name written across the heart belongs to the guy I've been calling Larry, and just below the heart, there's a date.
蛇眼。写在心脏上的名字属于我刚才称之为拉里的那个家伙，在心脏下方有一个日期。
December 23, 2007 is when I was brought to him.
2007年12月23日，是我被带到他身边的时间。
Why haven't you gotten that removed?
为什么你没有把它洗掉？
I actually-- it's hard for me to answer that question. It is a part of me that, when I look at it, it reminds me, at the end of the day, this past that I'm speaking of will always be a part of me. So I don't know if it's due to my lack of healing, or it's like a part that I haven't let go yet. I haven't moved on from it.
我实际上——很难回答这个问题。它是我的一部分，每当我看着它，它提醒我，归根结底，我所说的这段过去将永远是我的一部分。所以我不知道是因为我缺乏疗愈，还是因为这部分我还放不下。我还没从中走出来。
It's not like because I like looking at it, because I miss it, or-- I guess it's a reminder that it was real. But if you look in the tattoos, I have razor marks. I would try and cut them out of my own skin.
并不是因为我喜欢看它，或者因为我怀念它，或者——我猜它是一个提醒，提醒那是真的。但如果你仔细看那些纹身，我上面有剃刀留下的伤痕。我曾试图用剃刀把它从自己的皮肤上割掉。
Right there?
就在那里？
Yeah. I tried to take a razor and cut his name off of me.
是的。我试过用剃刀把他的名字从我身上割掉。
The whole time Kara was being trafficked by these gangs, she kept getting into trouble with the police. She says no cop ever asked her if she needed help. They didn't see her as a victim. They saw her as a criminal. She says nowadays, the police might ask her if she was being trafficked, but nobody asked her that back then. Kara says they'd just charge her with solicitation and tell her, that's what you got for being a prostitute. She'd get a ticket, have to pay a fine. Sometimes she went to jail.
在卡拉被这些帮派贩运的整个期间，她一直惹上警察的麻烦。她说从来没有警察问过她是否需要帮助。他们没把她视为受害者。他们把她视为罪犯。她说如今，警察可能会问她是否被贩运，但当时没人这么问。卡拉说他们只会控告她卖淫，并告诉她，这就是你做妓女的下场。她会收到罚单，必须交罚款。有时她还得进监狱。
The first time she got in trouble was in 2008, just six months after her 18th birthday. And then, again, in 2010, and again, and so on. Altogether, she was charged at least eight times in three different states-- Virginia, North Carolina, and Florida.
她第一次惹上麻烦是在2008年，就在她18岁生日后六个月。然后是2010年，又一次，以此类推。总共，她在三个不同的州——弗吉尼亚州、北卡罗来纳州和佛罗里达州——至少被起诉了八次。
In 2014, she and her trafficker at the time-- I'll call him Adam-- were on a long drive, headed to North Dakota for an oil boom. By then, they'd spent enough time together that he trusted her, let her have a phone. He'd actually rely on her for help planning their destinations. He'd be driving. She'd be in the front seat, scanning the news for parts of the country with sudden influxes of people.
2014年，她和当时的贩运者——我称他为亚当（Adam）——正在长途驾车，前往北达科他州应对石油热。到那时，他们在一起相处的时间够长，他信任她，让她拥有了一部手机。他实际上会依靠她帮忙规划目的地。他开车。她坐在副驾驶，在新闻中扫描国家哪里有突然的人流涌入。
I mean, that's how you'd figure out what city is going to hit, because--
我的意思是，这就是你如何算出哪个城市会爆火，因为——
Wait, so the trafficker or what have you basically, like, project manage the trafficking?
等等，所以贩运者或类似的人基本上是项目管理性贩运吗？
[LAUGHS] So I am-- [LAUGHS] I'm very versatile. Yeah.
[笑] 所以我——[笑] 我多才多艺。是的。
There was plenty of time to fill. While she was with Adam, she read the Divergent series on her phone, and The Hunger Games. She watched Law and Order, and she read the news. It was on this particular drive that Kara read an article about a woman who had been sex trafficked. Her name was Windie Lazenko. This was the first time Kara had ever seen that term, "sex trafficking," anywhere. And suddenly, the last seven years of her life, they weren't different, but her framework for them was.
路上有大把的时间。当她和亚当在一起时，她在手机上读了《分歧者》系列，还有《饥饿游戏》。她看了《法律与秩序》，也读了新闻。正是在这次特殊的旅程中，卡拉读到了一篇关于一名被性贩运妇女的文章。她的名字叫温迪·拉森科（Windie Lazenko）。这是卡拉第一次看到“性贩运”这个词。突然间，过去七年的生活并没有变，但她对它们的认知框架变了。
By the time Kara and Adam got to the North Dakota boomtown, they'd posted ads on Backpage. It was a Tuesday night, There was a pile of snow outside, and their ads weren't getting any bites. But she still had to make quota, so Adam sent Kara downstairs to the hotel bar so she could try picking up men the old-fashioned way. But something had changed, and she just didn't. She couldn't shake the article she'd read, so she sat at the bar drinking.
当卡拉和亚当到达北达科他州的繁荣小镇时，他们在Backpage上发布了广告。那是周二晚上，外面积满了雪，他们的广告没引来什么客人。但她仍然必须达到配额，所以亚当把卡拉打发到楼下的酒店酒吧，让她试着以老式的方式拉客。但有些事情变了，她没有去。她无法摆脱她读到的那篇文章，所以她坐在酒吧里喝酒。
I just wanted to go. I didn't care if, you know, what happened. I just knew that I had to find a way to get him away from me, because I couldn't get away from him.
我只是想走。我不在乎，你知道，发生了什么。我只知道我必须找到办法让他离开我，因为我无法逃离他。
Kara came up with a plan. There at the bar, she called a friend in Florida, said she needed help. She was about to go upstairs, back to her room, to tell Adam that she hadn't made quota. She'd leave her phone on with her friend in Florida still listening in. And not if, but when things turned violent, Kara's friend was to call the local police, pretend to be in the room next door, call in a noise complaint.
卡拉想出了一个计划。在酒吧里，她给佛罗里达的一位朋友打电话，说她需要帮助。她正要上楼回到房间，告诉亚当她没赚够配额。她会保持手机通话状态，让那位佛罗里达的朋友继续听着。而且不是“如果”，而是当事情变得暴力时，卡拉的朋友要给当地警察打电话，假装是隔壁房间的客人，报案说有噪音骚扰。
Kara's entire forecast was spot on. She went upstairs, told Adam there was no money. He made her strip down naked to prove she wasn't hiding bills anywhere. He got violent. He was yelling and hitting her.
卡拉的预判完全正确。她上楼告诉亚当没有钱。他让她脱光衣服证明她没有藏钱。他变得暴力。他对着她吼叫并殴打她。
And all of a sudden, there's a knock at the door. And I just looked at him. I said, it sounds like the cops. Let me open the door and tell him I just got out of the shower. Because they weren't going to stop knocking, and he knew that.
突然，有人敲门。我看着他。我说，听起来像是警察。让我开门告诉他我刚洗完澡。因为他们不会停止敲门的，他知道这一点。
Kara opened the door. Adam was arrested on the spot, and the cops booked him for domestic abuse. For once, a run-in with the cops didn't result in a ticket or a fine for Kara. And whatever that felt like for her-- overwhelming, relieving, confusing-- was immediately wiped away by another cop telling Kara that because she was staying in a room that was under Adam's name, she had to leave, on a very cold night in North Dakota with nowhere to go.
卡拉开了门。亚当当场被捕，警察以家庭暴力罪名关押了他。有生以来，和警察的这次交锋没有让卡拉收到罚单或罚款。无论那对她来说是什么感觉——压倒性的、宽慰的、困惑的——都被另一名警察的一句话瞬间抹去了：因为她住的房间在亚当名下，她必须在北达科他州一个非常寒冷的夜晚离开，无处可去。
Then I remembered her. I remembered Windie Lazenko.
然后我记起了她。我记起了温迪·拉森科。
Windie was the trafficking victim that Kara had read about in the car. She lived in North Dakota, the same state that Kara was in.
温迪就是卡拉在车上读到的那位性贩运受害者。她住在北达科他州，和卡拉所在的州一样。
And I got on the computer in the lobby, and I asked use the hotel phone, and I called her.
于是我在大厅的电脑上，借用酒店电话，拨通了她的号码。
After that, everything changed, starting with basics. Windie found Kara a bed to sleep in, clothes to wear, food to eat, and a job bartending so she could make a bit of cash. Adam pled guilty to domestic abuse, spent a short time in jail. Later, they charged him with promoting prostitution. Then, Kara says, she could have testified against him in court, but she feared for her safety, and so she didn't. The case was eventually dismissed. No one from his gang ever bothered her again.
在那之后，一切都变了，从最基本的事情开始。温迪为卡拉找了一张床睡觉，给了她衣服穿，食物吃，并为她找了一份调酒的工作，让她能赚点现金。亚当承认犯有家庭暴力罪，在监狱里待了很短时间。后来，他们指控他促进卖淫。然后，卡拉说，她本可以在法庭上出庭作证指控他，但她担心自己的安全，所以没有。案件最终被驳回。他帮派里的人再也没有骚扰过她。
And as soon as she saved up enough money, Kara drove back home to Florida. It was 2015.
当她存够了钱，卡拉开车回到了佛罗里达。那是2015年。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
So this is the part of the story where I explain the law that Congress enacted, what they wanted it to do, and what, in fact, it ended up doing, especially to Kara. Most people call this law SESTA-FOSTA. SESTA is short for Stop Enabling Sex Trafficking Act, and its goal was to stop sex trafficking by focusing on something really specific. The law would go after sex ads on the internet, like the kinds of ads Kara's traffickers posted. The lawmakers figured, get rid of all the ads, and you'll cut off a whole part of this market.
这就是故事中我解释国会颁布的那项法律的部分：他们想让它做什么，以及它实际上最终做了什么，尤其是对卡拉。大多数人称这项法律为SESTA-FOSTA。SESTA是“停止助长性贩运法案”（Stop Enabling Sex Trafficking Act）的缩写，其目标是通过专注于非常具体的事情来停止性贩运。该法律将打击互联网上的性广告，就像卡拉的贩运者发布的那种广告。立法者认为，去掉所有这些广告，你就切断了市场的一个重要组成部分。
Victims of trafficking had already tried to go after Backpage and sites like it for facilitating sex trafficking and prostitution even while Kara was still being trafficked, but most of those efforts failed because of something called Section 230. Section 230 basically says online platforms like Facebook, Twitter, Reddit, Craigslist, anywhere users post or leave comments, the companies that operate those platforms, they're generally not responsible for what users say. So if someone posts something defamatory or something that results in harm-- like if an exchange on a dating app leads to harassment in real life-- the social media platforms can't be sued.
性贩运受害者甚至在卡拉还在被贩运时，就已经尝试过起诉Backpage这类网站促进性贩运和卖淫，但大多数努力都失败了，原因在于所谓的“第230条款”（Section 230）。第230条款基本规定，在线平台（如Facebook、Twitter、Reddit、Craigslist等用户发布或留下评论的任何地方）的运营商，对用户所说的话通常不负责任。因此，如果有人发布了一些诽谤性的内容，或导致伤害的内容——例如，如果约会软件上的交流导致了现实生活中的骚扰——社交媒体平台不能被起诉。
Congress established this back in the early days of the web in the mid-'90s. It's a provision of the Communications Decency Act. But by 2018, celebrities like Amy Schumer and Seth Meyers were doing anti-trafficking PSAs, calling for a change to Section 230. Attorneys general from nearly every state signed a letter to Congress. And finally, Congress took action.
国会在90年代中期互联网发展的早期确立了这一点。这是《通信规范法案》（Communications Decency Act）的一项规定。但到了2018年，像艾米·舒默（Amy Schumer）和塞斯·梅耶斯（Seth Meyers）这样的名人在做反贩运公益广告，呼吁修改第230条款。几乎每个州的司法部长都签署了一封给国会的信。最终，国会采取了行动。
This bill is completely bipartisan from beginning to end.
这项法案从头到尾完全是两党一致的。
This is Senator Richard Blumenthal, Democrat from Connecticut, the day of the SESTA-FOSTA vote.
这是来自康涅狄格州的民主党参议员理查德·布卢门撒尔（Richard Blumenthal），在SESTA-FOSTA投票当天。
This bill essentially would clarify Section 230 of the Communications Decency Act that was never intended to give website a free pass to aid and abet sex trafficking.
这项法案本质上是要澄清《通信规范法案》的第230条款，它从无意中给网站提供帮助和教唆性贩运的通行证。
Lots of the outrage in the floor debate and several years of hearings that led to it was about children being trafficked.
在导致这一结果的议会辩论和几年的听证会中，许多愤怒都与儿童被贩运有关。
There are thousands of children out there who are waiting for our help.
有成千上万的儿童在那里等待我们的帮助。
Children are being forced into sex slavery.
儿童正被迫进入性奴隶制度。
We cannot allow our children to be lured into this kind of hell.
我们不能允许我们的孩子被诱骗进入这种地狱。
Just a word about that. Roughly 1/2 the federal prosecutions for sex trafficking in the US are for people younger than 18. The year of this vote, it was nearly 750 teens and children. And there have been cases of minors being advertised on websites like Backpage. 97 senators voted yes on the bill-- almost unanimous, Republicans and Democrats on the same page, which never happens. But SESTA-FOSTA didn't just ban ads for minors being trafficked, or sex trafficking in general. It banned ads for all paid sex, whether or not trafficking was involved, just to make sure that every possible case that could be prevented would be.
关于这一点多说一句。美国联邦性贩运检控案件中大约一半涉及18岁以下的人。在投票那年，有近750名青少年和儿童。而且确实发生过未成年人在Backpage等网站上被发布广告的案件。97位参议员对该法案投了赞成票——几乎全票通过，共和党人和民主党人站在同一立场，这在过去从未发生过。但SESTA-FOSTA不仅禁止了贩运未成年人的广告，或一般的性贩运广告。它禁止了所有付费性交易的广告，无论是否涉及贩运，只是为了确保防止任何可能的情况。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
And websites would now be responsible, not just for ads, but for any content anyone posted that enabled sex trafficking. That mandate was so broad that websites radically changed their rules to eliminate any possible posts that they could be sued for. Entire swaths of social media platforms, subreddits, Craigslist message boards, Instagram hashtags, and Twitter communities were suddenly gone. Tumblr, long known as the place for DIY alt porn, banned sexual content across their site.
而网站现在将不仅对广告负责，还要对任何人发布助长性贩运的任何内容负责。这一授权范围如此之广，以至于网站从根本上改变了规则，消除了任何可能被起诉的潜在帖子。大片社交媒体平台、Reddit子版块、Craigslist留言板、Instagram标签和Twitter社区瞬间消失了。Tumblr长期以来以作为DIY亚文化色情中心而闻名，在其网站上全面禁止了性内容。
Five days before SESTA-FOSTA was signed into law, Backpage was seized by the FBI. The site had long been the focus of a federal criminal investigation, and what SESTA-FOSTA did, as soon as it was enacted, was prevent a new hub from popping up in its place. By then, 2018, Kara had been out of being trafficked for three years. But it made me wonder--
在SESTA-FOSTA签署成为法律的前五天，Backpage被联邦调查局查封。该网站长期以来一直是联邦刑事调查的重点，而SESTA-FOSTA一旦生效，就防止了新的中心在其位置上涌现。到那时，2018年，卡拉已经摆脱性贩运生活三年了。但这让我感到好奇——
Had SESTA-FOSTA passed in 2008 instead of in 2018, do you think it would have gotten you out of being trafficked?
如果SESTA-FOSTA是在2008年而不是2018年通过的，你认为它会让你摆脱性贩运吗？
Absolutely not.
绝对不会。
Tell me why.
告诉我为什么。
Because there's other ways to be trafficked. Not everybody's trafficked on the internet. People act like that's the only way that there is to get money, and it's not just the internet. I would have still been trafficked. It probably would have been worse.
因为还有其他被贩运的方式。并非每个人都是通过互联网被贩运的。人们表现得好像那是获取金钱的唯一途径，但不仅仅是互联网。我仍然会被贩运。情况可能会更糟。
Worse because she knew very well what it was like to do the job without customers from ads. On days when Craigslist or Backpage didn't work, Kara had to go find customers herself.
更糟，因为她非常清楚在没有广告客户的情况下做这份工作是什么感觉。在Craigslist或Backpage不起作用的日子里，卡拉不得不自己去寻找客户。
You'd go to casino bars, truck stops, anywhere-- walk the streets. So yeah, I firmly believe if that bill would have been passed, it would have been worse. It's not going to help you out of being trafficked.
你会去赌场酒吧、卡车停靠站、任何地方——走在大街上。所以是的，我坚信如果该法案通过，情况只会更糟。它不会帮助你摆脱性贩运。
I tried figuring out if Kara's take is right, if the law really didn't have much of an effect on the trafficking business. Lawmakers definitely hoped it would reduce the number of people being trafficked. So did it?
我试着搞清楚卡拉的看法是否正确，该法律是否真的对性贩运业务没多大影响。立法者们肯定希望它能减少被贩运的人数。那么它做到了吗？
The best answer I could find is nobody knows. We don't know how to accurately count the number of people being sex trafficked, much less whether it's rising or falling. But we do know one effect of the law-- it's made policing sex trafficking harder.
我能找到的最好答案是：没人知道。我们不知道如何准确统计被性贩运的人数，更不用说它是在上升还是下降。但我们确实知道该法律的一个后果——它使得打击性贩运变得更加困难。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Since Backpage was seized, sex ads have scattered to lots of different sites where gathering evidence is more difficult. I spoke with a senior analyst at Uncharted-- that's a software company that helps law enforcement track sex ads on the internet-- and she said at least half of the sex ads that had been on websites in the US are now hosted by websites offshore, meaning the servers are in other countries, so whoever owns those servers is not obligated to comply with law enforcement or respond to subpoenas. Federal prosecutions of traffickers have actually fallen since SESTA-FOSTA passed.
自从Backpage被查封后，性广告已散布到许多不同的网站，在那里收集证据更加困难。我与Uncharted的一位高级分析师谈过——那是一家帮助执法部门追踪互联网性广告的软件公司——她说，美国网站上至少有一半的性广告现在托管在离岸网站上，这意味着服务器在其他国家，因此这些服务器的所有者没有义务遵守执法部门的要求或响应传票。自SESTA-FOSTA通过以来，对贩运者的联邦检控实际上有所下降。
I called one of the legislators who spent years going after Backpage and online sex ads, former Senator Claire McCaskill. She helped run a Senate investigation into the site, and she was one of SESTA-FOSTA's original co-sponsors. I wanted to talk to her about the law's intentions and how it's actually panned out.
我给多年来一直追捕Backpage和在线性广告的立法者之一、前参议员克莱尔·麦卡斯基尔（Claire McCaskill）打了电话。她协助主持了参议院对该网站的调查，她是SESTA-FOSTA最初的共同发起人之一。我想和她谈谈该法律的初衷以及它实际上是如何运作的。
If the aim is to curb trafficking, so far as I can tell, there's no evidence that trafficking has decreased as a result of the law.
如果目标是抑制贩运，据我所知，没有证据表明贩运因该法律而减少。
Well, you can't prove a negative. And this is one of the oldest problems in crime prevention. When you're successful at crime prevention, it's very hard to prove how you were successful. So there is no evidence to say that this bill didn't do its job. And so we don't know, and it's irritating to me that there seems to be this narrative that the sex workers are putting out there, well, it didn't do any good.
嗯，你不能证明一个否定论点。这是犯罪预防中最古老的问题之一。当你成功预防犯罪时，很难证明你是如何成功的。因此，没有证据表明该法案没有尽到它的职责。所以我们不知道，而且令我恼火的是，性工作者似乎在散布这样一种说法：嗯，它没有任何好处。
Well, they don't-- I believe that it does have an impact when people can't easily sell children online. I believe it in my bones, as somebody who prosecuted sex crimes for many years, that the ease of advertising children for sex, that going away is a positive in this country. That's not a negative.
嗯，他们不——我相信当人们不能轻易地在网上出卖儿童时，它确实产生了影响。作为一名多年从事性犯罪起诉工作的检察官，我骨子里相信，网上出卖儿童做性交易变得容易，能够让这种情况消失是国家的一个积极成果。那不是负面的。
When I asked her about SESTA-FOSTA making it harder to actually find and prosecute sex traffickers, she said law enforcement should, quote, "up their game." After SESTA-FOSTA passed, sex on the internet-- this won't come as a shock; there's a ton of it-- it all seemed suddenly radioactive. Not just advertisements for sex, it was true of all kinds of sex work, including people whose jobs are perfectly legal, like porn performers, camgirls, strippers.
当我问她关于SESTA-FOSTA让真正发现和起诉性贩运者变得更难的问题时，她说执法部门应该，引述，“加强他们的能力”。在SESTA-FOSTA通过后，互联网上的性——这不会让人感到震惊，那里有大量的内容——看起来突然变得具有放射性。不仅是性广告，所有类型的性工作都是如此，包括那些工作完全合法的人，如色情演员、摄像头主播、脱衣舞娘。
After SESTA-FOSTA, tons of them said that they were getting kicked off of Instagram and Facebook. Many of these were not explicit accounts, no nudity. Like one porn performer who posted a picture of herself on Instagram on Valentine's Day. She was wearing a tank top and mid-length red skirt, sitting on her bed, which she'd covered in rose petals. The photo was captioned, Happy Valentine's Day. By the next morning, her account had been removed by Instagram.
在SESTA-FOSTA之后，成千上万的人说他们被Instagram和Facebook踢出局。许多这些账户并不是露骨的，没有裸露。比如一位色情演员在情人节那天在Instagram上发布了自己的照片。她穿着背心和中长红色裙子，坐在铺满玫瑰花瓣的床上。照片配文：情人节快乐。到第二天早上，她的账户就被Instagram删除了。
The president of an adult performers' union told me she's documented more than 3,600 banned accounts. I reached out to Facebook, which also owns Instagram, and a company spokesperson responded, quote, "We understand that people sometimes disagree with what we do and don't allow on Instagram. We'll continue listening and responding to the concerns of our community."
一家成人表演者工会主席告诉我，她记录了超过3600个被封禁的账户。我联系了Facebook（它也拥有Instagram），公司发言人回应称，引述：“我们理解人们有时不同意我们在Instagram上允许或不允许的内容。我们将继续倾听并回应我们社区的担忧。”
Even though Kara wasn't being trafficked anymore, SESTA-FOSTA had an effect on her life-- a huge effect. I'll pick up her story in 2015, when she first returned to Florida. She'd been away for seven years, so she had no idea what to do, who to call, where to live. She tried finding a job, applied to lots and lots of them, but no one would hire her. She thinks it's because she had so many prostitution charges on her record.
尽管卡拉不再被贩运，但SESTA-FOSTA确实对她的生活产生了影响——巨大的影响。我要接着讲她2015年的故事，那是她第一次回到佛罗里达时。她已经离开七年了，所以她根本不知道该做什么、给谁打电话、住在哪里。她试着找工作，投了大量简历，但没有人愿意雇佣她。她认为这是因为她的档案里有太多卖淫指控。
Not even the Family Dollar would give me a job. Like nobody would give me a job.
甚至Family Dollar（平价零售店）都不给我工作。就像没人会给我一份工作。
You're saying if you would apply for a job, they would run a background check on you. And even though it's not a felony, the minute prostitution enters the picture, they're like, no.
你是说如果你申请一份工作，他们会查你的背景。即使它不是重罪，一旦出现卖淫的字眼，他们就会说，不。
Yeah, even Wawa. [LAUGHS] Those are the two jobs I was mad at the most-- Wawa, Walmart. Nobody would give me a job because of these charges. And it was mind-blowing to me, because I'm like, literally, it's a ticket in places. You don't even to go to jail, and you would not-- but because it was so frowned upon, because it was looked at as the nastiest, just immoral thing, these people would not give me a job.
是的，甚至Wawa（便利店）也是。[笑] 那是我最生气的两份工作——Wawa，沃尔玛。没人会给我一份工作，因为这些指控。这让我大为震惊，因为我想，这在某些地方确实只是一张罚单。你甚至不用进监狱，而你却不会——但因为它受到如此排斥，因为它被视为最恶心、最不道德的事情，这些人就是不给我工作。
I'm trying to do everything that I can to just live a normal life, just be normal, and it wasn't working. So my next option was to do what I knew how to do. That's why I jumped into the industry I knew how to survive on.
我试图尽我所能过上正常的生活，只是做一个正常人，但这行不通。所以我接下来的选择是做我已知如何做的事情。这就是为什么我跳进了那个我懂得如何生存的行业。
So in 2015, a couple of years before the law passed, Kara went back to trading sex for money, except this time, for the first time ever, she got to keep the money. There's an important distinction I want to make. At this point in her life, what Kara was doing was sex work, which means performing any sex act in exchange for money. Lots of things make it different from being trafficked, but the biggest one is Kara chose to do it. She wasn't being forced or coerced.
所以，在2015年，即法律通过的前几年，卡拉又回到了以性换钱的行业，只不过这次，是有史以来第一次，她能留住这些钱。我想强调一个重要的区别。在人生的这个阶段，卡拉所做的是“性工作”，这意味着进行任何性行为以换取金钱。许多因素使它与被贩运不同，但最大的一点是卡拉选择了做它。她没有被强迫或胁迫。
For the second half of her 20s, Kara's life totally changed. Not in some Disney rags-to-riches way-- though she was in Orlando-- but overall, she was happy. She knew it was illegal and that she was risking more criminal charges, but no one would hire her anyway, and by doing sex work, she was able to get her own car, her own house. Kara was putting herself through school. She got her GED, start going to classes. She wanted to be a medical technician. She was working towards certification. After that, she'd stop doing sex work. She had a plan.
在二十多岁后半段，卡拉的生活彻底改变了。不是那种迪斯尼式的从贫穷到富有的方式——尽管她是在奥兰多——但总体而言，她是快乐的。她知道这在非法，并且她在冒更多的刑事指控风险，但反正没人会雇佣她，而通过做性工作，她能够买得起自己的车、自己的房子。卡拉在努力学习。她拿到了GED（高中同等学力证书），开始上课。她想成为一名医疗技术员。她正在争取认证。在那之后，她就会停止做性工作。她有一个计划。
Nobody was in control of my life but me. I was empowered, man. That's the biggest word. I had the money to do and provide for myself.
没有人控制我的生活，除了我自己。我被赋权了，伙计。那是最大的词。我有钱做我自己的事，养活自己。
The way she made her money, the way she found her clients, it was all on Backpage. And you can probably see where this is going. When Backpage shut down, all of a sudden, everything that was working for her disappeared. Kara kept doing sex work, only it was more dangerous, she says. Backpage and sites like it made it possible for sex workers to share information about clients before agreeing to meet them in person. They could warn one another about predatory clients who, for instance, won't wear condoms, or refuse to pay, or try making sex workers include some service that they didn't originally agree to. It was a lifeline.
她赚钱的方式，她寻找客户的方式，都在Backpage上。你可能知道这是什么意思。当Backpage关停时，突然间，所有对她起作用的东西都消失了。卡拉继续做性工作，只是更危险了，她说。Backpage和这类网站使性工作者在同意亲自见面之前能够分享有关客户的信息。她们可以互相警告那些掠夺性客户，例如，拒绝戴避孕套的、拒绝付费的，或试图强迫性工作者包含她们最初没有同意的服务。那是她们的救命稻草。
Now, to get by, Kara started doing what her trafficker had her do on the nights that she hadn't made quota-- go outside, try picking clients up in bars. And when she would pick up a guy, she'd go into those dates totally blind. She says nothing violent happened to her, but she had less power. Clients started haggling and wanted to pay her less money. And over time, it got too hard. She couldn't post ads. She couldn't find clients. She wasn't making any money.
现在，为了生存，卡拉开始做她的贩运者在她没赚够配额的夜晚让她做的事——走到外面，尝试在酒吧拉客。当她拉到一个男人时，她对那些约会完全是一无所知。她说没有发生什么暴力事件，但她失去了主动权。客户开始讨价还价，想付更少的钱。随着时间的推移，这变得太难了。她无法发布广告。她无法找到客户。她没挣到钱。
I ended up completely losing the house, then, a couple weeks later, my car. So I was barely making it-- making enough money to even get by, let alone feed myself.
最终我完全失去了房子，然后，几周后，我的车。所以我几乎无法维持生计——勉强赚够钱度日，更不用说养活自己了。
After she lost her house, Karen moved into a hotel, one of those extended stay places. And to pay for it, now that so much of her work had dried up, she did find another job, as a cashier at 7-Eleven. She made $300 a week-- not enough to cover her room.
失去房子后，卡拉搬进了一家酒店，那种长期住宿的地方。为了支付费用，既然她的许多工作机会已经枯竭，她确实找到了另一份工作，在7-Eleven当收银员。她每周赚300美元——不足以覆盖她的房费。
For a short time, she tried sticking to her school schedule, going to class.
有一小段时间，她试着坚持她的上学计划，去上课。
But I ended up dropping out, because I just-- it was just too much. Like it was either survive or go to school. So it literally changed everything.
但我最终辍学了，因为我只是——压力太大了。就像是在生存和上学之间做选择。所以它确实改变了一切。
When I spoke with Senator McCaskill, I told her about Kara, about how she had been trafficked for so long, finally escaped, and got on her feet by doing sex work, largely through Backpage, and how SESTA-FOSTA made her job harder, more dangerous.
当我与麦卡斯基尔参议员交谈时，我告诉了她关于卡拉的事，关于她被贩运了那么久，终于逃脱，并主要通过Backpage做性工作站稳脚跟，以及SESTA-FOSTA如何使她的工作变得更困难、更危险。
The bill had this kind of big negative effect on her life, even though she's not a sex trafficker. And the law is supposed to be targeting traffickers. And so I'm wondering if this is a law that hits the wrong target.
这项法案对她的生活产生了这种巨大的负面影响，尽管她不是性贩运者。而法律本应是针对贩运者的。所以我很怀疑这是否是一项打错了目标的法律。
Well, I guess I would say that if you were sitting in the shoes of the Senate in those years, you would have seen websites that were helping people traffick children for sex. And they were being protected by a law, and they didn't deserve that protection. So the intent of the law was to stop trafficking of children for sex.
嗯，我想我会说，如果你在那些年里坐在参议院的位置上，你会看到那些帮助人们贩运儿童从事性活动的网站。它们受到法律的保护，而它们不值得那种保护。所以该法律的意图是停止贩运儿童从事性活动。
One of the byproducts of that is that for adult consensual sex workers, they have to find other ways to find customers. I'm not sure that any of the complaints about the difficulty of finding clients to pay you for sex is a fair trade-off for stopping a website like Backpage that was facilitating the trafficking of children across this country. And that's the weighing balance that we were looking at.
其中的副产品之一是，对于成年的自愿性工作者来说，她们必须找到其他方式来寻找客户。我不确定任何关于寻找愿意为你进行性交易的客户很困难的抱怨，是否是停止像Backpage这样助长全国儿童贩运的网站的公平折衷。这就是我们要权衡的平衡点。
I asked her about all the sex workers whose jobs are not criminalized-- porn, camming, stripping-- who say they've been thrown off of social media because of SESTA-FOSTA and now find it harder to make a living. She said that since they're doing nothing illegal, and nothing banned by SESTA-FOSTA, they should sue the social media companies. And she repeated her point about the law's intent.
我问她关于所有工作并未被刑事化的性工作者——色情表演、摄像头表演、脱衣舞表演——她们说因为SESTA-FOSTA她们被踢出了社交媒体，现在更难维持生计。她说既然她们没有做任何违法的事情，也没有做任何被SESTA-FOSTA禁止的事情，她们应该起诉社交媒体公司。她重复了关于法律意图的观点。
Honestly, I'm more worried about sex trafficking than I am how much money they're making stripping.
老实说，我更担心性贩运，而不是她们脱衣舞赚了多少钱。
Which, maybe that's the point. Congress cared about trafficking victims. They weren't focused on all the other people who'd get caught up in this law, including someone like Kara who actually was a trafficking victim. Just, she isn't anymore. Kara is not doing sex work anymore. She's getting by, but she's struggling. I told her the fact that she quit sex work, that the law made it so difficult for her to find clients, I think the lawmakers behind SESTA-FOSTA could see that as a victory.
也许这就是重点。国会关心的是贩运受害者。他们没有关注所有其他会被卷入这项法律的人，包括像卡拉这样实际上曾经是贩运受害者的人。只是，她现在不再是了。卡拉不再做性工作了。她还能过活，但她在挣扎。我告诉她，她辞掉性工作的事实，即法律使她找客户变得如此困难，我认为SESTA-FOSTA背后的立法者可能会将其视为一种胜利。
Like the law worked. You are a success story.
就像法律起作用了。你是一个成功的故事。
I highly doubt that they could use me as a success story. Let me make it very clear, I was still an independent sex worker for a while after SESTA-FOSTA, so it didn't work. SESTA-FOSTA didn't stop me. It hindered me a few times.
我非常怀疑他们能把我作为成功案例。让我说得很清楚，SESTA-FOSTA通过后，我还做了一段时间的独立性工作者，所以它没有起作用。SESTA-FOSTA并没有阻止我。它只是几次阻碍了我。
It got less safer. I wasn't able to be able to screen my calls the way that I should have. It became a headache, but it never stopped me.
它变得不安全了。我无法像应该做的那样去筛选我的电话。它变成了一个头痛的问题，但它从未阻止我。
It's funny-- it was always Kara's plan to stop doing sex work. She wanted to finish school, get a different job, try starting a family. But when the law passed, it threw a wrench in her plan. She made a lot less money at sex work, which slowed down her progress and her ability to reach her goals. So the law didn't push her out of sex work, she says. If anything, it kept her in it for longer.
很有趣——卡拉一直计划停止做性工作。她想完成学业，找一份不同的工作，尝试组建家庭。但当法律通过时，它打乱了她的计划。她在性工作中赚的钱少了很多，这减慢了她的进步和实现目标的能力。所以法律并没有把她从性工作行业挤出来，她说。如果有的话，它反而让她在那行待得更久了。
Lina Misitzis is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, new rules come down, and you think, I don't know, maybe I should just quit my job and get out of here. A very extreme example of that, that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
琳娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，新的规则下来了，你可能会想，我不知道，也许我应该辞掉工作离开这里。一个非常极端的例子，一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "There, I Fixed It." Stories of what happens when somebody throws the book at some problem. We hang out with the people who get bonked on the head with that book. In Act 1, it was the US Congress throwing the book. In Act 2, which we have arrived at now, it's the government of China. This is Act Two, "The Lonely Island."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“好了，我修复了它”（There, I Fixed It）。当有人全力以赴去解决某个问题时会发生什么的故事。我们和那些被那本书敲到头上的人呆在一起。在第一幕中，是美国国会抛出了那本书。在第二幕中，也就是我们现在到达的地方，是中国的政府。这是第二幕，“孤独的岛屿”。
So it's been a year and a few days now since China cracked down on Hong Kong with something called the National Security Law, which basically was Beijing saying to the people of Hong Kong, OK, game's over. Stop the nonsense. We're tired of your mess, the protests, the calls for free elections, criticism of China. The National Security Law lets China wipe all that away.
自从中国以所谓的《国家安全法》打击香港以来，已经过去了一年多一点的时间，这基本上是北京对香港人民说：好了，游戏结束了。停止胡闹。我们厌倦了你们的混乱、抗议、要求自由选举、批评中国的行为。《国家安全法》让中国可以抹去这一切。
And as a result, thousands of people have fled. The UK has extended a new kind of visa for Hong Kong residents that gives 70% of the population the ability to come live in the UK and apply for citizenship. When I was reporting in Hong Kong back in 2019, I met this writer named Karen Cheung. She spent the last year, since July 2020, when the law was enacted, watching Hong Kong change under the new law, in small ways and big ones and wondering if she's going to have to leave herself. Here's Karen.
结果是，成千上万的人逃离了。英国为香港居民延长了一种新的签证，让70%的人口能够移居英国并申请公民身份。当我在2019年报道香港时，我遇到了这位名叫卡伦·张（Karen Cheung）的作家。自2020年7月法律颁布以来，她花了一年时间观察香港在法律下的变化，无论是细微的还是重大的，并思考她自己是否不得不离开。这是卡伦的讲述。
Everyone I know in Hong Kong has a point of no return, a point when the situation deteriorates so irrevocably that leaving is the only option A friend from university says her point of no return is the day when Hong Kong is forced to write in the simplified Chinese characters used in mainland China instead of the traditional characters we use here. Another friend said that her point of no return is the day the police shot a protester. That happened in 2019.
我认识的每个香港人都有一个“不可逾越的底线”（point of no return），当情况恶化到无可挽回，离开是唯一的选择。一位大学朋友说，她的底线是香港被迫使用中国大陆使用的简体汉字，而不是我们这里使用的繁体字的那一天。另一位朋友说，她的底线是警察向抗议者开枪的那一天。那发生在2019年。
For a long time, my point of no return was when the National Security Law would be enacted in Hong Kong. I chose that because I thought it would be a long time before that day would arrive. Then, suddenly, last June, the law became reality. My point of no return was here.
很长一段时间里，我的底线是《国家安全法》在香港颁布的那一天。我之所以选择那个，是因为我觉得离那一天到来还有很长时间。然后，突然间，去年六月，法律成为了现实。我的底线就在这里。
The National Security Law is vague and broad, but what it comes down to is this. Every other day, we learn about something new that is now potentially illegal. The eight-word slogan we all chanted at protests two years ago, apparently, you can't say that anymore. Want to put up pro-democracy decorations in your shop? The police could show up. Even films that are about protests could be banned under new censorship guidelines. These acts could be considered endangering national security or trying to subvert mainland China. The maximum prison sentence for, quote, "grave offenses" is life.
《国家安全法》模糊且宽泛，但归根结底就是这样。每隔一天，我们就会得知一些新的事情，现在可能被视为非法。两年前我们在抗议中高喊的那个八字口号，显然，你不能再说了。想在你的店里张贴支持民主的装饰吗？警察可能会出现。甚至连关于抗议的电影也可能在新的审查准则下被禁止。这些行为可能被视为危害国家安全或试图颠覆中国大陆。所谓的“严重罪行”最高刑罚是终身监禁。
As soon as the law went into effect last June, we heard stories of people leaving. I thought I would be one of them. I'd always thought that when the day came, it would be an easy flip of a switch from Stay to Go. I'm only 28, and I have my whole life in front of me. It wasn't too late to start fresh in a new place.
法律去年六月生效后，我们立即听说了人们离开的故事。我以为我会是其中之一。我一直以为当那一天到来时，从“留下”到“离开”会是一个简单的开关。我才28岁，我的人生才刚刚开始。在一个新地方重新开始并不算太晚。
But I didn't leave. The seasons pass, and I keep looking for reasons to stay a bit longer.
但我没有离开。季节更替，我一直在寻找多留一会儿的理由。
Summer, July 1, the day after the National Security Law was enacted is the anniversary of the handover when Hong Kong was handed from Britain to China, and it's an annual tradition to march in the streets. By noon, the police held up a brand new purple flag that actually read, verbatim, "This is a police warning. You are displaying flags or banners, chanting slogans, or conducting yourself with an intent such as secession or subversion, which may constitute offenses under the HKSAR National Security Law. You may be arrested and prosecuted."
夏天，7月1日，《国家安全法》生效的第二天是回归纪念日，香港从英国移交给中国，街头游行是年度传统。中午时分，警察举起了一面全新的紫色旗帜，字面上写着：“这是警察警告。你们正在展示旗帜或标语，高呼口号，或表现出意图如分裂或颠覆，这可能构成《香港国安法》下的罪行。你们可能会被逮捕和起诉。”
Usually I'm out on the streets on July 1. Protests have been such a staple in Hong Kong for the past two decades. For me and everyone I grew up with, that's essentially our whole lives.
通常我会在7月1日走上街头。在过去二十年里，抗议一直是香港的主要内容。对我以及和我一起长大的每个人来说，这基本上就是我们的一生。
But this year, I don't go to the march. Instead, my partner and I anxiously watch the news with friends, all of us too nervous to head out. It already feels like a different world.
但今年，我没有去参加游行。相反，我和伴侣焦虑地和朋友们看新闻，我们都太紧张了，不敢出门。这感觉已经是一个不同的世界了。
There's a mass panic on social media. People worry they're going to be jailed for things they've said. They've started deleting their social media accounts, erasing their posts, changing their usernames. I want to yell at these people, the Communist Party doesn't even know who you are. Don't play into their hands. Don't obey in advance.
社交媒体上有一片恐慌。人们担心他们会因为说过的话而入狱。他们已经开始删除社交媒体账户，抹去帖子，更改用户名。我想对这些人喊：共产党根本不知道你是谁。不要中他们的计。不要提前顺从。
But the person I'm really saying this to is myself. I like to think that I'm at the far back of the line of people who will get arrested, because I'm a nobody. It's too early to know how and when the Security Law will be used on us, how bad it will be. Still, we take small steps so we can leave if we need to.
但我真正对自己说的也是这些。我喜欢认为我排在被捕人群的最后面，因为我是一个无名小卒。现在还太早，不知道《国安法》将如何以及何时会用在我们身上，不知道会有多糟糕。不过，我们还是采取小步骤，以便在需要时能够离开。
My partner and I get married a month later. We do this so that if we decide to leave Hong Kong, we can leave together. I only have a Hong Kong passport, but my partner has citizenship in an English-speaking country. We contact a lawyer, sign a piece of paper, and get married. I tell myself that this doesn't mean we're leaving; it's just in case.
我和伴侣一个月后结婚了。我们这样做是为了如果我们要离开香港，我们可以一起走。我只有香港护照，但我的伴侣有英语国家公民身份。我们联系了律师，签了文件，结了婚。我告诉自己这并不意味着我们要离开；这只是以防万一。
This may sound weird, but I don't know what my partner thinks about leaving. He doesn't bring it up, and I'm too scared to ask. When he does let something slip, it seems to change every few weeks or months. One day he says we could leave for 10 years and then come back when the crackdown has slowed. Other times, he vows to stick it out here. Sometimes, when my partner takes a bath, I slide into the bathroom, and splash some water on his face, and say, by the way, I don't want to leave, OK?
这听起来可能很奇怪，但我不知道我的伴侣对离开怎么想。他不提起，我也不敢问。当他偶尔说漏嘴时，意见似乎每几周或几个月就会变。有一天他说我们可以离开10年，然后等镇压放缓了再回来。其他时候，他发誓要在这里坚持下去。有时，当我的伴侣洗澡时，我会溜进浴室，往他脸上洒点水，说：“顺便说一下，我不想离开，好吗？”
Late at night, before we turn the lights off, I remind him that I really fucking hate the cold and that I have seasonal affective disorder. So if we ever move to a place above a certain latitude, we'd have to get a light lamp, and even then, I'd probably still be crying, and depressed, and resentful. Hong Kong is the only place I've ever called home.
深夜，在我们关灯前，我提醒他我真的该死地讨厌寒冷，而且我有季节性情绪失调。所以如果我们搬到一个纬度 выше的某个地方，我们得买个光疗灯，即使那样，我也可能会哭、沮丧和怨恨。香港是我唯一称之为家的地方。
Our generation grew up after the British left Hong Kong in 1997, and Hong Kong felt like it belonged to us. Our grandparents and great grandparents came to Hong Kong fleeing the war against the Japanese, or communist oppression. They thought about survival and nothing else. Some of them got rich along the way.
我们这一代人在英国1997年离开香港后长大，香港感觉属于我们。我们的祖父母和曾祖父母来到香港逃离针对日本人的战争，或共产党的压迫。他们只想着生存，别无他念。他们中的一些人在这个过程中发了财。
But my friends and I, we had dreams. We slept on couches and made zines about neighborhoods we love. We wanted to build community spaces, and live on farms, and play shows at industrial buildings, and protest till our bodies were spent. We weren't going to see this place as transitory. We would make this place our own.
但我，还有我的朋友们，我们有梦想。我们睡在沙发上，制作关于我们所爱社区的杂志。我们想建立社区空间，住在农场里，在工业大厦里演出，抗议直到身体疲惫。我们不会把这个地方视为临时的。我们会让这个地方成为我们的。
Even after the law, my day-to-day life hasn't changed much. I feel angry when I read the news. More than 10,000 people have been arrested for protesting in 2019, and every week, protesters are sentenced to many years in jail. But the messed up thing is, if I wanted to, I can still put on a swimsuit and go to the beach, or bitch about life with my friends at cafes, or sit for hours at my favorite bookstores like nothing has changed. The doom and gloom space in my head where people I've met or known have been arrested exists alongside the sunny, humid streets and country parks of Hong Kong. The storm hasn't hit us yet, and that's why we're still here.
即使在法律颁布后，我的日常生活并没有太多改变。读新闻时我会感到愤怒。2019年有超过10000人因抗议被捕，每周都有抗议者被判处多年监禁。但糟糕的是，如果我想，我仍然可以穿上泳衣去海滩，或者和朋友在咖啡馆吐槽生活，或者在我最喜欢的书店坐上几个小时，好像什么都没变。我脑海中那个关于被捕者或已逝者的悲观空间，与香港阳光明媚、潮湿的街道和郊野公园并存。风暴还没打到我们头上，这就是为什么我们还在这里。
Winter. The months pass. 12 Hong Kongers trying to flee to Taiwan on a boat are caught and detained in China. The founder of our biggest pro-democracy paper is jailed. A teenage protester who was shot by the police in 2019 has to go into exile. A journalist is arrested for doing investigative work.
冬天。月份流逝。12名试图乘船逃往台湾的香港人被中国拦截并拘留。我们最大的支持民主报纸的创始人入狱。2019年被警察射伤的少年抗议者不得不流亡。一名记者因进行调查报道被捕。
In early January, my partner and I have dinner at our friend's, who I'll call Beth. Beth's small, bright studio has a beautiful balcony with lemon trees and other potted creatures. Beth says she helped a group of her elderly relatives get their documents in order to leave. They tried convincing her to leave too, said they had fled to Hong Kong from China during the Cultural Revolution, and they were grateful to not have had to live through that.
一月初，我和伴侣在我们的一位朋友家吃晚饭，我称她为贝丝（Beth）。贝丝明亮的小工作室有一个漂亮的阳台，上面种着柠檬树和其他盆栽生物。贝丝说她帮她的一群老年亲戚整理了离开的文件。他们试图说服她也离开，说他们是在文化大革命期间从中国逃到香港的，他们很感激不必经历那些。
People in our parents' generation were always fleeing for stability, for better lives. But Beth and her partner have no plans to go. A few days later, I'm still in bed when, through the door, I hear my partner crack open a beer. It's only 10:00 in the morning, and he's already drinking, which means there must be another devastating development in the news. And I already know it will be a long day, week, month, year, eternity.
我们父母那一代人总是为了稳定、为了更好的生活而逃亡。但贝丝和她的伴侣没有离开的计划。几天后，我还在床上，透过门，听到伴侣打开一罐啤酒的声音。才早上10点，他就开始喝酒了，这意味着新闻里肯定又有了毁灭性的进展。我知道这将是漫长的一天、一周、一月、一年、永恒。
That morning, the police had arrested dozens of pro-democracy activists. Their offense? They ran in a primary for an election that the government keeps postponing. It's the biggest single-day arrest so far. Weeks later, in my day job, I read about their trial. An activist on trial tells his pregnant wife that he loves her as he's facing an indeterminate number of years in prison.
那天早上，警察逮捕了数十名支持民主的活动人士。他们的罪名？他们参加了一个政府不断推迟的选举的初选。这是迄今为止单日逮捕人数最多的一次。几周后，在我的日常工作中，我读到了他们的审判。一位受审的活动人士告诉他怀孕的妻子，他爱她，因为他面临着不确定的多年牢狱之灾。
I realize I have to compartmentalize and stop reading the news at work unless I want to start bawling in the office in front of a dozen coworkers. Sometimes, the reason you want to leave isn't related to danger. It isn't that you give up. It isn't that you think being somewhere else will bring you a better life. It's that your heart can't take it anymore. Maybe what will get me to leave is not fear, but fatigue.
我意识到我必须把工作与生活分开，停止在工作中阅读新闻，除非我想在十几位同事面前痛哭。有时，你想离开的原因与危险无关。并不是因为你放弃了。并不是因为你认为在别处会带来更好的生活。而是你的心再也承受不了了。也许让我离开的不是恐惧，而是疲惫。
After the mass arrests, that's when people around me start actively discussing leaving. Soon, at dinner gatherings, the only thing my friends and I talk about is whether to go or stay. Some sign up for language classes and join Facebook groups to learn about life in foreign countries.
在大规模逮捕后，周围的人开始积极讨论离开。很快，在晚餐聚会上，我和朋友们谈论的唯一话题就是走还是留。一些人报名参加语言班并加入Facebook群组，了解国外生活。
When I see Beth again, her plans have changed. She and her partner have volunteered during the election and done work with international non-profits. They start getting worried about their safety, too. Beth is leaving soon for school overseas, and she's trying not to think about whether she'll come back. I ask them what they are going to do with their plants, which they care for like their babies, and they groan.
当我再次见到贝丝时，她的计划已经变了。她和伴侣在选举期间做过志愿者，也参与过国际非营利组织的工作。他们也开始担心自己的安全。贝丝很快就要去海外读书，她尽量不去想自己是否会回来。我问他们怎么处理那些被他们像婴儿一样呵护的植物，他们叹了口气。
Every time someone tells me they're leaving, I picture them fading into the background one by one around a rosy dinner table, until there is only me left, staring at my plate. I try to imagine living in the Hong Kong where they're gone and all hanging out at a bookstore together in London, discussing Hong Kong news without fear that someone will eavesdrop. It makes me want to throw myself into Victoria Harbor.
每次有人告诉我他们要离开时，我就想象他们一个接一个地在红色的餐桌旁淡出背景，直到只剩下我一个人，盯着自己的盘子。我试着想象住在他们离开后的香港，而他们都在伦敦的一家书店里聚会，讨论着香港的新闻，而不必担心有人偷听。这让我甚至想跳进维多利亚港。
I don't tell them any of this. The public conversation around leaving has become so fraught. People judge you if you're going on about your new life abroad or see you as a deserter. Some people left without saying goodbye, not out of fear, but shame. I don't want my friends to think I'm judging their decisions, but it also means I never say out loud how much I can't bear to see them go.
我没告诉他们这些。围绕“离开”的公共讨论变得如此紧张。如果有人谈论他们的新生活，人们会评判你，或者视你为逃兵。有些人离开时没有告别，不是因为恐惧，而是因为羞耻。我不希望朋友们认为我在评判他们的决定，但也意味着我永远不会大声说出我有多无法忍受看着他们离开。
Whenever my friends press me on my plans, all I can say is, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know-- which is true. After coming home from gatherings which increasingly feel like farewells, my partner and I still don't talk about our plans. Talking about it makes it feel real and imminent-- too soon, like we're going to leave tomorrow.
每当朋友们追问我的计划时，我只能说，我不知道，我不知道，我不知道——这是事实。从那些越来越像告别聚会的场合回家后，我和伴侣依然不谈论我们的计划。谈论它让它感觉真实且迫在眉睫——太快了，就像我们要明天离开一样。
When we talk about who gets to leave, that discussion is inevitably tied to class and upward mobility, and therefore privilege. New visa policies mean that a lot more people get to leave now, but some still can't afford it. And for people whose arrests are imminent, they don't have the luxury of discussing what their points of no return are. The fact that I am having this internal debate, that I am neither in exile or in jail, is a privilege.
当我们谈论谁能离开时，这种讨论不可避免地与阶级、向上流动性以及因此而来的特权联系在一起。新的签证政策意味着现在有更多的人可以离开，但有些人仍然负担不起。而对于那些逮捕迫在眉睫的人来说，他们没有奢侈去讨论他们的底线是什么。我正在进行这种内心辩论，即我既不在流亡也不在监狱，这就是一种特权。
Spring-- in April, I'm scrolling through the news feed and see that the government has come up with something truly out of this world. It's called the National Security Education Day. Photos show little children holding fake guns and all sorts of weapons-- kids barely old enough to have pocket money, but already training to be cops. Schools are introducing patriotic education, and teachers can lose their teaching license for having views that are deemed politically incorrect. I close the browser and think, there is no fucking way I ever send a kid of mine to a school in Hong Kong.
春天——四月，我在滚动浏览新闻提要，看到政府想出了一个真正天马行空的东西。它被称为“国家安全教育日”。照片显示小孩子们拿着假枪和各种武器——这些孩子甚至还没到有零花钱的年龄，但已经开始训练当警察。学校正在引入爱国教育，教师如果持有被视为政治不正确的观点，可能会失去教师执照。我关闭浏览器，想，我绝不可能把我孩子送到香港的学校。
Recently, I sat on the back of a motorbike as a friend drove us through Hong Kong Island. The honey-hued streets at night are quiet. All I can hear is the wind roaring by us and the metronomic hum of the traffic lights. We pass by a rubbish truck tainting the air sour, and I noticed paint clumsily smeared on the side of the road to cover up graffiti of now-illegal slogans. We meander through the stench of bitter Chinese herbs in Sheung Wan and one we're on Victoria Road, all we can smell is the damp soil.
最近，我坐在摩托车后座，一位朋友带着我们穿越香港岛。夜晚蜂蜜色的街道很安静。我只能听到风在我们耳边呼啸和交通灯单调的嗡嗡声。我们经过一辆空气酸臭的垃圾车，我注意到路边笨拙地涂着油漆，试图覆盖现在被视为非法标语的涂鸦。我们穿过上环苦涩的中草药味，而我们在维多利亚道上，唯一能闻到的是潮湿的泥土。
We stop at a stretch of waterfront, so far away from the light pollution that I can look up and see the stars. I feel a flood of existential dread. I had never seen the city on the back of a bike before. How many more ways are there to experience the city I thought I already knew, and how can you possibly tell me to leave before I have checked off all of them?
我们在一段滨海地带停下，离光污染如此遥远，以至于我可以抬头看到星星。我感到一股存在的恐惧感。我以前从未骑过摩托车体验这座城市。还有多少种方式可以体验我以为我已经认识的城市，而你又怎么能在我打卡完所有这些体验之前就让我离开呢？
We often speak of Hong Kong disappearing as the doomsday scenario, as though the city would submerge underwater like Atlantis. It is much more likely that one day in the near future, the Hong Kong cityscape will not look unlike how it had in 2020, but there will be nobody here who remembers the place that once existed. This is what I fear most-- that the skyscrapers will remain intact, the countryside hikes still beautiful, and the harbor rippling with nightlights. That you can still go to work and have afternoon tea at hotels, and outwardly, you can't tell anything is wrong, but the only ones left here are those who believe this is the best version of Hong Kong there could ever be.
我们经常把香港的消失视为世界末日场景，好像这座城市会像亚特兰蒂斯一样沉入水下。更有可能的是，在不久的将来的某一天，香港的城市景观看起来与2020年并没有什么不同，但这里已经没有谁记得曾经存在的那个地方了。这是我最害怕的——摩天大楼完好无损，乡村远足径依旧美丽，海港上闪烁着夜灯。你仍然可以去工作，在酒店享受下午茶，表面上，你看不出有什么不对，但留在这里的唯一人选，是那些相信这是香港有史以来最好版本的人。
I don't know what will happen in the next few years or even weeks, but I know that when it feels stupid to stay, like it does now, suddenly, something as small as a discreet box on a minibus stenciled with the words, "gaa yau," "I support you, keep holding on," could be enough to make our day seem less bleak. We talk about the question of staying or leaving like there is a right or wrong answer, a clever or irrational choice. But there's really only one question-- whether or not you're ready to say goodbye. And I know I'm not ready yet. For now, I choose limbo.
我不知道未来几年甚至几周会发生什么，但我知道当留下变得愚蠢时，就像现在这样，突然间，小巴上一张印着“加油”、“我支持你，坚持住”字样的小盒子，可能就足以让我们的日子看起来没那么黯淡。我们谈论去留的问题，就好像有一个正确或错误的答案，一个聪明或不理性的选择。但实际上只有一个问题——你是否准备好告别。我知道我还准备好。现在，我选择停留于此。
Karen Cheung. Just in the last few weeks, as Karen was recording her story, things have gotten worse in Hong Kong. Journalists have been arrested. The big pro-democracy newspaper Apple Daily closed. Three activist groups disbanded. Karen says some of her friends who weren't planning to leave are now reconsidering.
卡伦·张。就在最近几周，当卡伦录制她的故事时，香港的情况变得更糟了。记者们被捕了。《苹果日报》停刊了。三个活动团体解散了。卡伦说，她一些原本没打算离开的朋友现在也在重新考虑。
[MUSIC - T.A.T.U. - "NOT GONNA GET US"]
[音乐 - T.A.T.U. - "NOT GONNA GET US"]
With this week's show, producing has gone through so many hands. Lina Misitzis, Laura Starecheski, Nadia Reiman, Aviva DeKornfeld, and Bim Adwunmi. Other people who put together today's show, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Beth Lake, Rudy Lee, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ari Saperstein, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
本周的节目制作经过了许多人的手。琳娜·米西齐斯、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）、娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）和比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adwunmi）。其他参与今天节目制作的人员包括：苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、达米安·格雷夫（Damien Graef）、贝丝·莱克（Beth Lake）、鲁迪·李（Rudy Lee）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、阿里·萨珀斯坦（Ari Saperstein）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks today to former Senator Heidi Heitkamp, Jon Courtney, Lana Wilson, Alan Yu, Clara Ma, Alex Andrews, Blair Hopkins, The Sex Worker Outreach Project, Behind Bars, Keith Chu, Bella Robinson, Ramona Flour, Lorelei Lee, Scott Cunningham, Greg DeAngelo, Aaron Sankin, Gustavo Turner, Julia Robertson, and Congressman Ro Khanna, Alex Levy Yelderman, EJ Dickson, Alice Aster, Kevin Schowengerdt and Emily Wyatt. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢：前参议员海蒂·海特坎普（Heidi Heitkamp）、乔恩·考特尼（Jon Courtney）、拉娜·威尔逊（Lana Wilson）、艾伦·余（Alan Yu）、克拉拉·马（Clara Ma）、亚历克斯·安德鲁斯（Alex Andrews）、布莱尔·霍普金斯（Blair Hopkins）、性工作者外展项目、Behind Bars、基思·朱（Keith Chu）、贝拉·罗宾逊（Bella Robinson）、拉莫娜·弗劳尔（Ramona Flour）、罗蕾莱·李（Lorelei Lee）、斯科特·坎宁安（Scott Cunningham）、格雷格·德安杰洛（Greg DeAngelo）、亚伦·桑金（Aaron Sankin）、古斯塔沃·特纳（Gustavo Turner）、朱莉娅·罗伯逊（Julia Robertson）以及国会议员罗·康纳（Ro Khanna）、亚历克斯·列维·耶德曼（Alex Levy Yelderman）、EJ·迪克森（EJ Dickson）、爱丽丝·阿斯特（Alice Aster）、凯文·肖文格特（Kevin Schowengerdt）和艾米莉·怀亚特（Emily Wyatt）。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He recently misplaced a tooth that he was hoping to get tooth fairy money for-- just lost it. Drove him crazy.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他最近丢失了一颗牙齿，本来希望能得到牙仙子的钱——刚丢的。这让他快疯了。
It invaded all aspects of my life. Any room I walked into, I looked in the corners. I looked under the table, crouched down.
它侵入了我生活的方方面面。走进任何一个房间，我都会查看角落。我会查看桌子底下，蹲下来检查。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。